nothing go home nothing go home do you
think it's okay to shout down an
offensive speaker more college students
than you might expect say yes according
to Fire's 2024 college free speech
rankings 2third of college students say
shouting down a controversial campus
speech can be acceptable in some
circumstances one quarter say it can be
acceptable to stop the speech with
violence at schools like UNCC and
Oberlin the number is closer to half and
the results of the survey reflect actual
activities on college campuses it's
called a heckler's veto and it's a form
of censorship it's what happens when a
group of people makes it physically
impossible for a speaker to be heard and
for Willing participants to listen
speaker shout Downs are concerningly
common on American college campuses they
don't show any sign of stopping and many
are even defending this form of
censorship as more
speech